Respect and justice in
equity the campus based diverse
perspectives and can be to the
minions learning and- it is our
hope that our during tonight's
event will be able to engage in
respectful dialog this is these
core values as stated it CSU SB
policy on speed advocacy.
Students in fact in the
university enjoy generally
accepted rights check him they
are free to express their
opinions and views without the
ship and all settings and
education activities that are
sanctioned university please be
advised any disruptive activity
during. The restrict the
freedom of expression of our
presenters or poses a risk to
public safety will not be
condoned now please join me in
welcoming to the stage sh. Man
president in V. P. Democrat
fairs. Thank you let me clarify
I'm not the president at this
great institution I am provost
Richard. The end of academic
affairs. I not be half of
president braless we want
extend our warm welcome and
thank you for being here. To
engage in this important very
important dialogue. We are
honored to be chosen for as the
fight for the assembly select
committee on the status eight
which is the second hearing and
we are also grateful for the
rich. Learning experience and
make opportunity this hearing a
for its for our students and
other campus community members.
As you are well no cal state
sambar dean. Is dedicated to
providing access to quality
education we instill the
knowledge and confidence needed
to help our students succeed.
And we seek to inspire them to
be engaged and caring community
members. And efforts are driven
by our core values which are
innovation. Inclusivity
respect. Social justice and
equity and safety and wellness.
Together our main campus and
satellite campus in palm desert
serves approximately two
hundred thousand students we
have over a hundred thousand
alumni of which we know that
six thousand of them live
within fifty miles- of this
campus so in the Inland Empire.
And these rates are hoping to
expand our work for us and
improve the qualities of life
our communities I want to
extend a further thank you to
assemblyman assembly member
Richard bloom and our other
distinguished us. Up for your
work to examine X. and explore
ways to effectively address is
thing rate of Hey Pete in our
communities and beyond and I
would also like to thank C. S.
B. isn't center for the study
eight an extremist for their
efforts to aid scholars. Berman
officials long Brent and others
with objective information to
support their examination
limitation of law education.
Policy so thank you very much
for being here. Good evening
everyone we are in the assembly
district and it is my great
privilege to introduce my
colleague assembly member James
Ramos. Thank you of the rest of
this the committee that's here
today and- James Ramos the
something fourteenth assembly
district or cal state
university- resides in but
today we're here on a topic
that addresses in a touch is
all of us especially were at an
assembled here today. In this
op this man well student union
center- named after my great
grandfather when we talk about
the state of hate and
information here gonna take
place here today we have to
please remember the native
American pop. Gen that suffer
great. Atrocities and genocide
here in the state of California.
My great great grandfather
sciences when well who's- out
of the mountains these
mountains right in a thirty two
day war we're shooting and
killing took place where our
clan almost until depend to non
existence these are the topics
there still are very much
relevant here in the state
California. And we continue to
see the process of moving for
technology in those acts that
take place. In this area and
earlier this year the governor.
Formal apology to the
California. For the trustees
and genocide that took place in
the history of the state of
California and those are the
issues that the select
committee continues to move
forward and bring to light and
it's my honor to have them
assemble here in the fourteenth
assembly to pick to touch on
all those topics that are
there. The chairman Richard
bloom represents the fiftieth
assembly district which
encompasses West Los Angeles
Beverly hills Aurora hills
Malibu Topanga many other
communities that are there. And
as a member. Member bloom was
born to a Jewish family and
Reyes Altadena and West Los
Angeles and attended Fairfax
high school so he knows exactly
the issues facing us today and
retain light assembly a panel
to discuss the issues. That are
relevant to pay for up to
center around and rise as a
community to rise in the face
of the adversity that's in
front of us to make sure we
have respect for all people
that includes all of us.
Sitting here today so it's my
honor to be able to open up and
welcome select committee here.
Today to the cap to university
salmon Dino. I'm a district so
chairman for bringing this
vital information to our area.
You very much for. Your very-
moving during the opening
remarks. To the provost Telfer
cam make welcoming us to the
beautiful campus I have to say
first time at the campus and I
am very impressed with a
beautiful location I understand
you're all coyotes- you can how
anytime you want. But it is a
pleasure to be here I also want
to welcome my a call from the
Senate and the assembly I'm
going to give a few opening
remarks if that's all right and
then you'll have an
opportunity. To add some
remarks and then we'll move on
to our panelists but- I am the
chair of the Senate select
committee this is a select
committee that was formed a
couple of years ago at my
request of the speaker of the
state assembly and- he agreed
to let us start having some
meetings around this issue of
hate and to explore ways that
we can. Understand it and the
address it and I want to again
thank cal state San Bernadino
for hosting us and partnering
with us and again- from
assembly just forty assembly
member James Ramos we also have
with us here today-
representing all the
representing the beautiful-
Inland Empire assembly member
Jose Medina assembly member
Eloise radius and- senator.
Richard Roth. Thank you. Now
we're all here to talk about a
particular topic today and
unfortunately white
supremacists in the United
States of experienced a
resurgence in recent years the-
wake up call for all of us I
suppose was the unite the right
rally in Charlottesville- that
is not that long ago was twenty
seven. Teen at route extracted
about six hundred extremists
from around the country and
sadly ended and deadly violence.
Modern white supremacist
ideology is centered on the
assertion that the white race
is in danger of extinction
found a rising tide not quite
people who are controlled and
manipulated by Jews. A white
supremacist believe that almost
any action is justified if it
will help to save the white
race. The hard to speak- but
sometimes it's hard to speak-
in accurate terms about some of
the things going on in our
country now after the twenty
sixteen election white
supremacists- which also
frequently known as the all
right- but grew. Our on line
active them through and with
group in order is in. In
tactics such targeting. College
campuses like the one we're on
today. The all right also
expanded to its propaganda
efforts through tactics like
podcasting in world of online
games where. Are they targeted
an influence young
impressionable individuals. Our
who were listening and readily
of. Audience violence and crime
represent the most serious
problems emanating from the
white supremacist movement
white supremacists have killed
more people in recent years
than any type of domestic
extremist fifty for of all
domestic. Stream is related
murders- of all. Stream related
murders. Of them were committed
by white supremacists. And this
is not just people who have
adopted this as an ideology it
is also who are influenced by
the ideology- or by the
rhetoric and so- I just this
past weekend we serve the one
year anniversary of the tree of
life synagogue attack that
occurred in suburban Pittsburgh
where eight people were killed-
the LA perpetrator of that
process he- was found to have
white now. List directly on.
His cell hard drive on his
computer. Murmurs in terror
plots represent only this guy's
got a of this kind of file. As
there are many more pensive.
That may have ended in by.
Including attempted murders
thoughts weapons and explosive
violence but they didn't.
Because I are at law
enforcement was able to get
their first in addition white
supremacists engaged in a lot
of non ideological. Including
crimes of violence women and
drug related crimes. Well these
groups represent only a small.
A small. The overall population
they are not in sick again in
their influence and are
becoming increasingly ticketed
and organized in some cases
they have formed alliances and
created umbrella organizations
is the national front they have
changed their parents to seem
more professional and rebranded
their organizations with
adopted names like the national
policy institute to appear more
academic. An effort to change
the political landscape they
have created political is like
the American Freedom Party to
elect local state and national
candidates and it is. That
their mission is to infiltrate
the mainstream and attack
American values. So what do we
do how do we slow down this
proliferation how do we diffuse
this growing type of hate how
can we bounce free speech with
incendiary hate speech on so I
made yeah. As it is in our
thirties how do we prepare our
communities to be able to
handle potential for taste.
Hosting hearings says these.
Will guide us I hope towards
finding answers to these
questions and more which. Out
will allow us a better ability
to take on these things head
on. Today we have with us for
expert presenters who will be
covering different. Nationalism
at C. outlined in the agenda
after they have concluded their
presentations- week of bill
around five thirty will be.
Comment period. Be invited to
voice your opinions and
concerns getting to the subject
matter of this hearing. We do
ask that you hold all of your
questions and comments until
the conclusion of the program.
When we hold public comment
period. You can do this in two
ways there are our cards and
their green cards if you would
like to speak of fill out a
pink card you don't have to put
the address information are
your name will be sufficient
enough information so that I
can call you and identify you
to come down and speak. And if
you just want to make a comment
submitted to us so it's
something that we read- later
on that would be the green card
put your comment on there and-
I assure you we will be copying
them and providing them to. All
of the participants. And again
I want to take a quick moment
to thank some of the people who
are here today- I'll begin with
our four presenters at the
table across from me. We have
professor Brian okay I should
say CSU espys. Professor Brian
look. From the center for the
study of hate and extremism.
Thank you thank you what to do
let me repeat the center for
the study of hate and extremism
it's extraordinary that we need
there to be such a center. Also
equally extra. That CS US is- a
host here on this campus and
then it gives us thank you. We
also have with us Rick eaten of
the Simon Wiesenthal center
located in my district Rick
thank you very much for being
here- deputy sheriff Greg Jones
from the San Bernardino county
sheriff's department. And joins
us from Detroit is Jeff scoop
who led the largest ****
organization in the United
States up until eight months
ago- that was the national
socialist movement- needed. To
by the American party. And Doug
I think we're all gonna be
riveted a job what you have to
say and thank you for being
here and for having turned over
a new leaf in your life. And be
able to help us understand this
phenomenon that you were once
involved in. I woke ugh again
want to thank my colleagues
from the legislature for being
here and invite them now to
make caught beginning with.
Assembly member Jose Medina.
Well first of all. Thank you
but to cal state San Bernardino
for hosting us here- and to
assembly- bloom for- hosting
the bring this committee. I'm
assembly member who they Medina
represent the sixty first
assembly. Sites Marin of early
and the city of Paris. And as I
sit here I see some of my
former colleagues said poly
school fellow teachers and
counselors sitting here on this
very important topic. In
riverside we saw. Neo ****
coming to temple Beth el on the
night of service. I saw the
same group of protest inner
having demonstration in front
of the- home people were day
labor we're working. And I'm
very happy that we're having
this year because as our number
bloom a stated we've seen the
rise of hate in the last three
years and I've been in my own
district seen incident after
incident happening and I think
it's very important that stand
up to hate so very happy to be
here. The seat. Assemblymember
press. I do want to thank.
December Dino you're not of my
district but you're in my heart
have of many of my that. Did
you once- our students here
alumni as is my husband it's a
great institution I always
enjoy coming here is it my
colleague assembly member James
Ross. Who represent to you I
want thank. Assemblymember it
is first select committee
hearing in may and I'm so
pleased to see. It kills the
Dino for the second. And I'm
also very please with the
panelists he has been able to
bring to us today this is such
an important topic just as my
colleagues talked about. This
is that is affecting all. It
affects our communities that
affects our neighborhood. It
affects our state to our nation
and our entire world we have to
be prepared. We do we have to
understand this into concept.
Many of us felt it have
experienced it personally. This
focus. On combating anti
somatic Islamophobic homophobic
and racist behavior I'm so glad.
Yes this to a as I look out
thank you someone. I get the
form turns I get de Ollie.
Friends from my district so
good to have all of you here.
Young to join together to know
more about. All we have to be
able to do to combat this just
as a committee. Says it's going
to do and it knowledge is one
of the most. That we can have I
do. This is the. Gov I E. with
of the empire. I he. Then I
want you to think of inclusion
body because this is what the
Inland Empire stance for.
Senator. Thank you Mister chair
of my Richard Roth and I the
state senator this privileged
to represent- western county
big shout out to see issue
sambar today no. I just want
you to know we said are you to
be riverside counties cal state
as well. Sure very important
topic I really want to tell you
how much I appreciate you
inviting me to participate in
your select committee and I.
Look forward to do here. It's
going from the panel and the
further discussion so thank you
very much thank you and. The
end of the. We're all extremely
busy with our schedule and
there are times when we can't
we try to ten the entirety a
hearing but it's not very
frequent are able we were able
to actually stay for the entire
hearing so thank you that
amount of time that you are
able to spend plus. I'm and
without I would like to begin
with our- discussion will begin
with professor Brian Levin- who
will be speaking about global
state of white supremacy and
how it is manifested. Itself in
our communities. Chairman bloom
and is the members of the
assembly instead. Professor
Brian Levin thank you and our
wonderful campus I love them
all. So very much for the
opportunity to present our
Jeanne latest linings on
prejudice and extremism mostly
from our report to the nation
twenty nine in fact book on. My.
This is directed to ms. Your be
able to do without him. One in
his space. If you win teaching
award they give you. You are.
And or or as provost and vice
president. For academic affairs
you're a good man the my hope
is the same- with referencing
an organist pop culture and
products. And confusing the
blues and we are but. Someone
from the governor fairs as as
well again- about she she said
with extreme team of
researchers. Throughout the
country but all. Hi this rally.
That out. That turned the. This
is almost ten years ago to the-
that's. Missy brings to. Season
mission. Moral position say
something this is. Not. This
your. Whatever the rainbow.
Your trust. The nation's
aspirations ironically during a
time a letter to synagogue in
nineteen seventy one. We the
government to be not age. Which
gives to bigotry no sanction to
prop you should know with this
to. Record they under. Cells is
good for the- on all occasions
there are factual support I
want to thank the governor of
the state a cal. The something
else I do a lot with a lot of
legislative folks particular
the staff. And people from. The
state department. America and
we should stop undermining the
institutions. Of our
pluralistic democracy when we
were talking about. You might
eloquent when we should have
some more day look at this a
white supremacist for writing.
The threat facing the whole.
This is. The trick why. Budget
killed at least twenty six. For
this year. Each year. Budget
the press. Killing. So we tell
you. Also turning up as- right
to be the voice. Was a graduate
of cal state Los your husband's
family church attack I will
continue to go to Washington I
continue to go to Sacramento
anything I can do to get common
sense gun regulation. This
center is going to do. And I
keep my promises on the. So I'm
not laws well we do have an
applause line limit. You were
not in your district twenty.
Three twenty nineteen will
person overall downward trend
in America. The homicide. Your
site. What. Here's a look
here's a look at a wonderful
grafted I did not do you can
thank Dr Christian. I'm sure
that. The graph. Just. Hi.
Homicide state. We just. All of
we track things. Two or three
one was a white supremacist
involved. At will. Adam. Burns
dean in Orange County. What.
For two days off lower white
nationalist first internet
platforms or force multipliers
record and disseminate graphic
violence but notices the GMAT
test does as well in the
scripted online full of
violence these views are
disturbingly come. In the rural
population this is all before
el also. Then or July report.
So talk about this connection
or prop. And prior Matt session
and also. Two three these kind
of attacks before the July a
trap. To place our- also. What
he crimes are. In two thousand
where 31% leased out of twenty
she- do you low. Twenty
fourteen. Hello hi. Are you
sure you're gonna have to wait
for the FBI stashing the number
twelve we go out before him
because we want policy a policy
makers long force legislature's
job most up. To date
information twenty eighteen are.
The largest cities in a three
thirty. Nine that's the. In
hate crimes in his largest
cities this. The national. The
trims the will we'll see we'll
see we'll we'll see in November
that goes California cities
again same picture all. Your
report found a spike to find I
think we're having. To reprint
but look at the cities we're
talking about Los Angeles San
Francisco for instance can get
hot in twenty Jim Bob but for
the film number please that we
had and I had just updated
billion get a chance to put it
in the in the power. Point New
York LA Chicago likely to. In
many cities New York Los
Angeles Phoenix. Up in twenty
nineteen as well. Here's
something interesting but one
day my friend judge John actual
who worked in. This graph as
well and James known as region
universe. No. Work for. To see
what this okay to. Select text.
Look. We're trying to do the
now just. Some kind of action.
With extreme is the tux. This
is all coming at a time in the
U. S. elation person. And also
coming. I went and social
pollute. The youngest
demographic is the one that's
diversifying the most from the
most recent shootings that we
see in mass shootings Gilroy
which we have in the church
exactly what that one is but if
you look at power when you look
at el Paso. But. Did have. Five
up quite significantly recently
I am the youngest court is
group that is. The first single.
So the one that's the most
aren't except for. It
radicalized on the internet we
see the sea change used to be
the organized groups like Nash
George was moving now wishing
smaller groups with shorter
help lives to more violent and
we're also seeing the do it
yourselfer come from an
ecosystem. Of hate that they
find on a buffet from the
internet. This is the
diversification United States.
Now the minor party. This is.
Tuitions. Continued multi Gen
thanks to. Hold us to get. What.
All politically were show up.
The polarization and we're
getting engaged in the
political process. And one
things have to be sure. Is
there seems to be some
correlation. Catalytic pull all
of that troll or election day
after let twenty sixteen the
worst day for hate crime going.
Up D. C. two thousand three and
it was also a time of a plot to
blow up. Apartment gardens.
What we saw on assassination of
a member of parliament taxed so
we're trying to find out or the
signal literature we make some.
For research well policy policy
makers law. Well brown. 75%
Protect what last plan.
Research. On does with the
signs. Also nine. Shop all
right. This is what we see what.
Later. One interfere okay what
is this. He was. Committee
minority time. The run twenty.
We need to step up and take
measures to protect our
elections from interference. A
plus là. More today than my
twenty years. So this. One
thing for you for over. Two one
on the stuff to. About twenty
five years ago opens anyway. He
looks older bomb this is from
government. That. Two right
right wing. Direct not children
okay. This is. Relation of the
right wing so a Los Europe.
What's happening this thing
just bear with me on this look
at the wrong. I'm not sure.
Good will. Right very pleased.
We will twenty the latest data.
Okay well. In a year we were
seeing. White supremacist white
now. Rally in the two years
leading just into an after
Charlottesville on the previous.
To try to get me stream one
tamp down but if. For instance.
Lose our into one. Other chart
showed month by month. We had
about two years would to
celebrate. And look what
candidate Obama was about to
win October two three eight
however it's still to stop
November twenty sixteen so
trying to analyze that. You're
a- the group. Work. Others
which. Watch. You know. You dot
dot. Up to it true to life
shooter a year ago. He
understood the guard because he
of the killer believes.
Immigration so it's just a list
of some of the attacks.
Shooting a más friend injuring
two you can also we- all of.
And we were. Red from the you.
Notice again. Right size up. In
Europe we see as many. The tech
looked a big. In the region and
I this might be a week. Still
to lose power more. Some other
stuff yeah. Be sure. The anti
defamation. The medic a charge
state does not 20% cities track
twenty eighteen. More over we
see. And again the worst of
violence against Latinos and
indeed the worse for right it's
still bloom is the bombing el
Paso worst attack in American
history and use. A Pittsburgh
so we're seeing this ramping up.
Of violence. To be easier to
just like one. The bomb scares
bye bye just the what one one
person in the previous year
anyway I'm off to Mike my buddy
of more years and the rest will
admit. The summit more. We'll
see of the more diverse law but
then four G. so thank. The
justice department of a college
and university the old vote
sentiments. Thank you so much
for have. And I like the
introduced Rick Eaton who is a
senior researcher with this
woman Huizen fall center.
Chairman bloom assembly man
members and there's another
dignitaries here to- with the
university as Simon Wiesenthal
center thank you for holding
informational hearing. And
drawing attention to this
extremely burden timely
subject. As professor Levin as
outlined we have witnessed far
too many incidents of murder
and mayhem and by hate. It is
time to put the phone four
squarely back on to me.
Understand fully eight of what
Nash to my- for me it back.
From the eighteen sixty zero
out the White Sea but was
dominated by a handful of yours
some of you see. Ian Pearson
national dance a former physics
test organ university Richard.
A nation is in a. I keyed top
at Fallbrook California. At
Haley lower thanks. You are
losing our list here today just
group. By two thousand five
Pearson Butler were gone. Hale
was serving a forty year prison
term for soliciting the murder
of a federal judge and you're a
grown old and ineffective as
well as losing a six million
dollar judgment. Against
himself his son and his
organization. Low like you know
also moved and expanded. For
okay allowing the following
that the move was some right
listen to twenty fifteen. Seven
generate. Running from the
topic where Richard and Sir of
the national policy the two
two. Well known for his from.
B. the end to end when not yet
of at least. In twenty fifteen
when then candidate trump
targeted immigrants and made
his proclamation yes almost.
Those who are that then calling
them as well as you said
founder and it it and a call.
They had never recent years
ever for any. It became for
approaches online sure almost
anyone who disagreed with the
president's candidacy
frequently using racism and
anti semitism bolstered
arguments one of the bill is
used to promote the so called
all right arm which was coined
by Spencer was okay to be
white. As if somehow and prior
to that. They even gave this
conflict on line it came that
all the eight me more. On the
screen is first of two anti
semitic postings this entire
thing a Jewish report. For
right thank. In Canada and the
set one up you is one. The
actor Emmy Rossum which was.
After that. When said that
crime spike at that time this
is. Because it I she had post
Iraq post something on line and-
this was a research on her.
This is all of your ilk sure.
You'll all be staying in. Sure.
Hey Chad to get dinner all not
familiar with the imagine this
and are there with the- trump
name on it is actually the
gates of Auschwitz Birkenau
concentration camp where our
proximity million people order
during the Holocaust. The thing
that we saw during and after
the campaign. Nine later events
right later came the events in
Charlottesville what was unique
about your bill was that this
new generation. Had made a
concerted effort to make them
more palatable to a mainstream
audience. Although a few
swastikas in cat and
Confederate flags were in
evidence the machine. Fields
for non group does. Our. This
is the advertising for it. Even
the yeah this is also a- the
bill used most the rally make
your pager thing take in
Franklin's famous to you the in
their own goes into a. I these
are some of the logos that we
side Charlottesville Ted very
non descript- so you last you
knew these war you really will
now most would represent. I in
J. national socialist move. The
on the left that was eight
shields used to the riverside
and eleven. I with the swastika
on it. And this week from Xur.
But still bearing Dahle room
the symbolist. During the so
called torch March. I at
Charlotte for the main road
route. Choose to participate in.
Through the campus. Yeah. And
we're chanting slogans. In the
top you will not river he says
and it was hello but you will
not place. This is part of the
White now. Right now. Sure four
hundred presented by for
Pittsburgh. One year ago this
week. Post this map sites I'll
get. The mass read it I H. I.
L. he Brough image eight IT.
Thanks for bringing that bears
the kill our people I can't by
watching people get water screw
your optic time go again. H. I.
a S. is nearly a hundred and
forty year old organization
whose purpose is mainly is
settled it refugees who have
have come to this country
because they are risk in their
home. Countries of persecution
violence and war. At times the
H. I. a S. has even been asked
by the U. S. government to help
settle refugees. Bowers Bowers
believed in something called
the replacement is been
mentioned previously. On about
among white can live as well
genocide immigrants are brought
into the country with a
specific person of rip
restricted purpose of replacing
or genocide white people mainly
through- birth rates. Badly
with today's. Witness sedan
after incident of burger citing.
This full op including just
five this group that have
happened it passed. Positive
result did emerge from
Charlottesville. The tragic
death of their higher counter
protester a number of the new
site internet sites belonging
to these white supremacists or
white nationalists were de
platformed and excluding the
aforementioned daily stormer.
Sites such as go on me and
Patrick. Now almost white this
page and the credit card
providers- said out not when
they tried to set up their own
sites do the same thing. In
addition the largest social
media networks including
Facebook YouTube took a very
have a closer look at their own
rules and began removing white
nationalist postings. This has
moved many but not all the
white nationalist sites in the
individual. To turn platform to
be on the screen well this is
our in many que is echo
chambers them so also you
present a danger. After to the
deadly event listed the
previous law. These it's rob
with adult. Urgent for us to
take action. A host of no less.
No less violence in smaller
groups in loan actors have
sprung up in the past few years
include. Thank you know not be
Adam office. This is rob about
movement and the prop boys
scribe cells as well. In this
part of something. That we all
right is this. Man is fear.
Interesting enough others have
described. This group as as a
multi racial white supremacy
group. Because they have they
have- tried to change their
image and even have used a
front man from one of their-
one of their divisions that is
an African American but the
philosophy still remains the
same. Two final category so
like to draw your attention to
are gaming and messaging. With
the loss large so the meeting
last six trips have looked into
coming. In become a. To contact
potential met since the most
popular names are used to
promote this is what. The in
home. Which is in discordant
which have and million just
private. Budget was being young.
In addition game which makes
available. Why which were used
in the in the recent attack on
the synagogue in Halle Germany
just this past year on could
pour. And live streaming was
also used in Christ in the
Christchurch attack and would
have been used in the PO a
synagogue attack except they
had it he had a technical
glitch the social network
providers inability an apparent
lack of interest in solving
this issue despite calls from
the Simon Wiesenthal center and
others is both glaring. And
unacceptable. This is just one
one. A. Truck games or at night.
The most popular games a
popular game in two thousand
eighteen. Excerpted messaging
apps have been used by both
white nationalist and Islamic
terrorists with impunity. On
multiple occasions I have
personally made near
instantaneous contact with
white supremacists and even
ISIS figures in Syria. Just
wall hold my phone. If you wish
and is present Lake do this
imagine what she'll followers
can a cop. If they believe in
the lot. Back to the- national
socialist movement you to say
AB is also shown on there. On
with uber of others. That were
we will have been you spot the-
telegram is another app that
has become extremely popular
the white nationalist says it
offers both one to one
communications- and billet to
create a regular feet if you
download telegram subscribed to
this feed. You can get their
messages on a regular basis-
and del have hyperlinks and-
take you right into the to
whatever propaganda they're
promoting at the time. In
conclusion let me thank you
again for dry much needed
attention to the subject of
hate as a state we need to
increase our awareness and
monitoring and force our
existing laws and determine
where we make might. Be digital
progress. The internet has
become the fuel that powers
much of the hate and violence
resulting from white
nationalist ideology. To this
end the Simon Wiesenthal
center's created a program to
discuss the perils of social
networking with middle and high
school students. Been able to
make this program available in
southern California through a
cal yes grant. Piloting
preventing violent extremism
programs. We need to continue
to repeat such. We need to
continue to reach young people
in this manner in the hope that
we can avert them from. A full
activity in the future thank
you. Thank you very much next
up we have deputy sheriff Greg
Jones the community liaison
with the San Bernardino county
sheriff's department to keep us
a long term perspective on this
issue. Thank you very much.
Hello okay. Thank you very much.
I would like this I would like
to think because these
aboriginal and all the
Assemblymembers. And are
senator center Roth- and also
the pay for this opportunity- I
represent assembly you know
county department ensure John
it man. And it was a pleasure
to be here. My perspective from
this a little bit different.
Which you just heard what you
just seen is extremely in
detail- it's very this topic is
very very happy it's a hard
topic to talk about- it's one
of those things that being in
the community liaison. Where
are county I hate always comes
up. Always comes up it is a
discussion that is definitely
need to be had. You may not
want to talk about it is
definitely needed. And the only
way to talk about it is in a
former this so like to thank
you. I really want to get to.
And explain from a personal
standpoint- when law
enforcement response to calls
for service- we don't always
see- what in and in the end I
season. Tom what we see some
more likely as a hate incident.
Individuals have a freedom of
speech regardless of how an
individual may or may not feel
about it. The hard part is
investigating hate crimes as
all. One of the key incidences
that to be a crime. I'm gonna
go through my presentation is
not as long as my counterparts.
I just wanna give you a very
brief understanding because I'm
very interested to hear from.
Jeff. One of the thanks of hate
crime it has to be within the
seven in the Decatur. Hate
crime mean to cut back in order.
Our part because. Receive so
the big. Yes nationality rate
at the. Region's Tory Xin. The
per room. More of these actual
seat the rest. And the heart.
That's the hard part. When it
comes we see a lot of hate
these days in the media. We see
a lot of it on the net. And
also the state level- whether
you're on one side of the party
or the- party. These are really
part are cut our county or
state or. You don't have a look
see hate. When we get hate. We
within one of these
characteristics. The difference
is when someone there is a hate
incident. It's either if all
under. Hey by. This will
protect other person right most.
Examples include in calling in
Salt. But it's just being hate
real in a public place. Meeting
bill on your own prop. In this
room alone. How many
individuals have been a victim.
I hate incident the going back.
So if you really think back
everyone has been a victim of
it in support of some type. And
it affects everyone. When it
comes a speech the first clip.
The issue with that is. Speech
protect most speech. We just
three of the if the for her
words. The speech number two.
Right perjury black I'm in.
Section can see. In within say
like how do we are confined to
education within our law
enforcement officers are law
enforcement health standardize
Bob hope's piece all. Was gonna.
Our training is my post. Like
most states in the in state.
The our prisons. Some go. Under
the guidelines. It's the same
throughout the entire United
States. It's not. We're very
forty. Every off to me go to
training we what we get the
necessary information. From
post. We received
approximately- right now it's
twenty four weeks of. Within
those four weeks we have
approximately two hours the
deals will culture per city.
Implicit bias. Within that we
recognize that the culture-
within the cal thing
California's pass if you. We
look at. So what's for our
enemy in for every person see
our camp to our enemies every a
and C. we even have outside
agencies riverside county.
Agencies north with me. We're
trying to. Negative. If
somebody actually. Or the right
I'm it with it. Taking that
into the six months almost
impossible. So when we come
across with the public and they
want to express that their a
victim of a hate. It's our
responsibility in law
enforcement. To give an
understanding of what hate it
hate speech or hate crime maps.
We should now. The hard part is
our officers are very
challenged. It's not an excuse
at all but I do need to make a
very clear and hopefully we can
understand that include our
panel. That when it comes to
culture diversity. We're given
a lot information. But not just
like everyone here has been
affected by hate of hate speech
I hate incident it's not clear
when it comes a law. For one it
has to be a violation of the
law. When we go back. When it
comes I hate crimes we are
taught laws related take Raimes
does. Related impact of crime
best get in documentation. We
are trying to the site. The
initial investigation is not by
an officer or a deputy. I'll go
to the law to a scene doses of
the church Gen. They will get a
good treatment for council or
whatever is needed. We have. We
will. But the basic investigate
is all basic education. Is
hammer the lowest also a- is it.
It will be. Eight cation
bearable. Mason the detective
FOR investigator will look at
in a raven enough information
from disability the tender
nationality race religion
sexual orientation association
with the person group of one or
more of the perceived
characteristics. From now will
look at the local playgroups.
Look at the local organizations
we'll look at the patterns that
are being developed within our
our our sister agencies
surrounding counties. Their
crimes have been committed well
look the patterns- we are very
fortunate that our department
as part of a regional task
force. That task force- is made
up of multiple agencies within
southern area. We meet
quarterly at the anti
defamation league. We meet with
other individuals- I can't go
into detail all the different
agencies because some of that
is confidential. But I can't
tell you that our regional
partners. Some of the liaisons
are with the FBI. Sometimes we
were on a local. Sometimes
group like a group that Jeff.
For the national. A lot of the
hit happens within our own
state in a rural county. This
is are coming from the area. It
is very deceiving. I was
looking at the city it's with
you to. I've. I was very aye
right that is Lara county it's
not always over twenty thousand
square miles for this year
alone we've only documented
seven hate crimes. This year.
Last year was twenty. So the
question comes up. The
reporting for the team's not
wanting to be victims they
afraid or the exchange is under
reporting is it on the Japanese
or the officer side is a
training or experience. This is
just phone the number a little-
but said of the tax. This is
this for now this is our our
alone. It is how do we about
hate crime how do we truly
investigated is it a hate
speech Hey incident. We do it
has crime. A lot Hey there were
saying is starting at the
university at the university
level a lot of his to social
media. Live it is to the gaming
systems. A lot of his on the
national level. It's not hard
to find a hate group of some
type. Issue with. You have
individuals going seeking out
individuals who feel like
they're being pushed aside. In
their grooming them. It's
starting in the schools. One of
the aspects of the way one
person is handling the their
hate crimes is that we're
taking a deeper look into what
is what is the ultimatum or
what is the actual what is the
evidential. What is at the root
of the issue. If you feel the
been a victim were you know a
victim please report it. I
cannot stress that enough I
would have to think that we
have more hate crimes in just
five or seven with our own
county. If you're from outside
county like riverside or Los
Angeles. Sometimes we look at
certain counties is with more
of a population. But if it is
room alone if we've had many
individuals been affected by
hate. Think about all the
individuals who are not.
Because they don't want to be
percent they don't want to be
on social media. They don't
want to be verbally and there
can be verbally attacked. About
casein investigating hate
crimes. They're very hard very
hard to prove. Look at the
intention. The larger ones were
the other rallies and you have
somebody putting a truck
through a group of individuals
the easy to investigate it's a
motivated that person to kill
somebody did not look like them
because of eight. Park ones is
if you have in our county the
which with the incident. On a
school bus where you have kids
who hanging a noose. Outside of
a school bus. Driving down the
road. It's eight is children so
what do we don't want. We start
with educate. With with going
out talking visuals we meet
with Burke. We meet with
individual that may not agree
with us meet with groups that
made that. I'll be with us. But
we need each and everyone of
you when you see something is
not a slogan we see something
say something. Become part of
the change we need your help.
We need every is assembly
members help because we have a
closet thank change. Done
because nobody's ever feel like
a victim. No reserve right I
can't report something or I
don't mean anything. Hate is
hate. Thank you. Thank you our
final speaker is Mister Jeff
scoop who is the former leader
of the national socialist
movement welcome and thank you
for being here. Thank you-
assembly member bloom I'm
honored and humbled to be here
and nam. All the on the
assembly thank you very much.
Where to talk a little bit
about- the start out with
inside right national. Look it
by not is America this. This
I'm was. Two years ago. Seven
thousand seventeen. Actually
some. This just. I'd like to
apologize to the local
community for- depart my
organization had in. Some of
the incidents that took place
here over the years. It's not
easy to get up here and after
twenty seven years in the
movement to admit that you were
wrong that- the life that you
lived. My entire adult life was
wrong in in correctional so-
here with me a little bit of
from- slow in the- delivery of
the speaking here you know I
spoke for many years in the
national socialist movement and
I can tell you. I don't all
those years this is probably
one of the hardest speeches-
I've ever had to give because-
it's not easy to admit one's
wrong with. For the past so
let's move on here. In the
early years- just like to tell
you a little bit about my story
and- where I come from and all
and so on so you can kind of
get an idea the public can kind
of get an idea of where how
people get involved in this
movement and- going forward
from that- that's me as a as a
small child. And so we all
start out like this. Yeah this
is a- one. Of my people that.
Are we're all human in a lot
time see. I think out in the
outside world because of Haiti
because the nasty things that a
white. Man has done- especially
some of the horrible incidents
like we have we heard about
here today like the synagogue
shootings the mosque shootings
and stuff like that. I think
it's easy to dehumanize people-
and so to realize or or to
believe that- we're not dealing
with human beings here so- at
the risk of coming off as an
apologist for these people I
certainly am not that but I
want people to understand that-
you know this is a this is a
two way street and someone
explain kind of how. And why I
join the movement. Can't see
this picture very well this
looks like a rally I think this
is here in California. I also
want to. Get into a little bit
of a cop deal. People to move a
lot of. That. All this is about.
Do you eight some I can tell
you some I come from a middle
class home I didn't have a
story like a lot of the other
performers do where they were
beaten up they were bullied
they came from all one family-
home- they had all these
problems with drugs or or her
struggles and things like that
I came from a very good decent.
Normal middle class family and
I got brought into this
movement I was in this movement
until. March of this year. Is
so people can come from all
walks of life and get involved
in this sort of thing. Com. So
there's me again. This was a
long time ago. Nineteen ninety.
And Rick. Find find common now
please hello with one that
ample religion. The US and
they're there. I just Christian
idea and we I mean to the point
that I recall it was not target
at one Civic we tarp that you
think could. Up specific things
like religion. And give them an
identity which says that the
white race is the chosen people
of god. Experiences if someone
came to us and said you know-
for example a female I had been
raped by somebody of another
race we would play on that we
would we would focus on that
issue because once they're in
there and then some of the
other things that. Maybe they
didn't agree with or didn't
understand everything. If we
get him in the door we get him
in the door that's all or
that's all we were trying to
DO. Hatreds so someone came to
us and said they don't like
black people or they didn't
like Jews you know we would
expound on that we had
literature specifically
tailored to all of those
different things whether it
was- crimes between the races
whether it was the Jewish
question whether it was. God
that was saying it's religion
we had things that were based
on all these different things.
Then through recruitment we did
it I mean every aspect
everything you can imagine.
From video games from music.
From leaflets to podcast I
think the national socialist
movement now even today has
probably five podcasts a week-
which- to video games in the
last few years. Hello all kinds
of different. Basically. To
combat these type things what
we need to do is. Some no bill.
And you saw those things
because once people get all in
this and I keep saying I don't
like to. Cult but in a lot of
ways it is like a call because
you are you living life in sort
of a bubble. And you don't see
outside that bubble life is so
much different from me now
because I'm outside a bubble
like it's like a whole new life.
Group of human beings like when
you were in the movement. You
are in your mind is closed-
many different things. I was I
was top story on the way over
here. Another guy that had
gotten item is a year before I
didn't. You know my sound crazy
to be. When I holding for first.
Look around where that is the
another race we talked I see
that today and I think. That's
the time. Was that we had a
most. That is the. It's just
only battle just like a small
act of kindness that normal
right you know I didn't see it
was things. My. I want to draw
off my experience improvement
and doing now. Here I believe.
And I know a lot of hello. That
sort of thing speak this sort
of thing is pretty easy. In the
movement when you leave your
hair like originally I just
retired from the movement
that's that's easy you can
retire. No big deal. When you
start speaking out and do this
sort of. They look at that as
if you are the worst kind of.
The worst kind of in the tool
bar. When I dropped my
experience my knowledge
movement. How they think the
psychology of that why they do
what do to combat this. And to
help this is my way of giving
back- for a lot of people that
question sincerity. Why am why
I'm doing this sort of thing.
We put for me or mental state I
was that I knew what I was
doing. In in this world in a
sense of how to do the work
business tied in with this
every I knew. Because this was.
I was doing for all those years
was on I knew was wrong to go.
But I get out. Why. Because it
was easy a stock- like a guy
that that's working at a terror
that he hates everyday and just
keeps doing doing in. I'm not.
That I'm ashamed to say it but
it's true. It will be easier to
stay where I was at why I
didn't stay any longer is like.
That was coming violence that
was already happening and the
violence that's to calm if we
don't. Come back there in the
correct manner. And drop. My
experience at this when I talk
to you station. In this way
state and that that's a one I
didn't even know number years
ago. Like this and having a
conversation trying to- expound
the- ideology I'm assuming of
the movement. He was knocked
out on the street and people
were laughing and they filmed
it and kind of walking over him
I think people might have been
spitting on him and filming it
nobody help this young man. So
at the time when I was in the
movement and we use videos like
this all the time to you know.
Promote our cause and save like
what we were doing was right.
When I join the movement I
thought I was doing what was
right I thought I was standing
up for my people. And that's
what a lot of the people that
are involved in that their
idealists. They believe they're
standing up for their people
that's why this is going to be
a hard thing to break. They're
not joining a because they just
blindly hate. Me there is those
types in there too. But I'm
saying for me personally and
for a lot of the people that I
knew. It was about ideology it
was about. Trying to save the
white race as we reckon and
some of the other panelists of
kind of- touch upon here the
thinking of these guys- in
that. So under the de
humanization subject. Gene this
young man treated like that in
a lot of people don't. Gosh why.
Steal so for the for this guide
I got knocked out in the street.
Because at the time.
Minimization of I. But now
since. I see that wow. A white
person when they couldn't see
the teaching in a the de
humanization of so many others.
You see not that we- didn't
come to me until out. Until
after I had time to. Decompress
my mind in fiscally look back
and go wow you know I could see
the human is a of this guy. The
structure that I didn't. Being
somewhat that propagated hate
and- intolerance and all this
sort of thing for all these
years I didn't see that did you
realization of all those other
people. See it now. That's why
I feel like there's hope. For
all of us if we can. Hey. In
the photo on the left. A rally
that's me there's being with.
Yes ma'am. Other groups that.
Thank you thousands. On right.
Marla by default. Yeah that's.
It's a it's a psych hate
reading violent. Island see a
Peavey is as one of things I
work with now- which profit
called networks that happens
people leave of various forms
of extreme some extremism can
come in many forms- is not just
the far right. The far left is
up here- G. hot of mints and
other types of extremism. We
see it whether it's gang
members or or- all the
different kinds of extremism
anti far far right jihadi a
Muslim extremist. Types of
extremists- when they leave
wrong period. So I'm this this
is what I should had up here
okay we have. It may be item
we've that basis for it Bob in
sum up. Any yeah okay others
may find some I know that. Okay
on the right today but felt it
is important to point out the
other forms of extreme because
they are all up dangerous.
Polarization. Stream question
understanding hi. I know that
hard pill to swallow. But if.
One of one of the most of it is
that that I've seen getting a
number of other people are.
With you when I. And I've
brought people a few from other
position if you were
independence and people from
the group and I always keep my-
two of those. As I know we can
reach a lot of this bill that
are never going to. Virtually
no matter if someone were for
me tenure ago I probably
wouldnt of. Left either- but we
have to understand that be
compassion and understanding.
Does that make not everybody
can but I know I know that
that's not even possible for a
lot of people. But you have to
understand and this is this is
why I'm here today to explain
how this works and how they
think and how they feel.
Extremists feel isolated. There
increased isolation will only
further radicalized them. As I
mentioned about simply holding
a door for somebody of another
race. The movement there's
people won't even go to ethnic
restaurant they won't go in see
certain movies they won't- they
won't even talk to somebody
about the race or or- after.
You know so these people are
ready self. Self isolated so
it's very hard to reach people
like that so a lot of times
simply breaking through that
polarization and getting them
to understand- that what that
your human being too I mean
this is a lot of. A lot of the
ways it broke it down for me it
was originally I'm from
Minnesota and I moved to
Detroit in Detroit the whites
are a minority I had I was
forced basically to deal with.
People of all. On a daily basis
for many many so many wonderful
people from all different
racial backgrounds and started
during their store wow this
person's family is no different
than mine this person had the
same struggles but I do and-
listing is that sound when
you're in this. Cult like
environment or in this bubble
Utah. Beyond that you don't see
that Solana times simply
humanizing the person sitting
across from you and getting
them out of that isolation
treating them with compassion
and kindness- really works a
friend of mine. Of Daryl Davis
is a black guy that goes in its
hands clamped meetings and
befriends Klansman and a lot of
people think general's
absolutely crazy I told when I
first minimized you are crazy.
But what he does works because
he'll sit back home. All those
stereo types. And fire coming
out bodies. Because we all have
commonalities with differences.
Frances are so much less. Than
the common at these in the
similarity between all the
people of different races. But
it was harder before you see so
we can do that as a as a come.
People as human beings we're
gonna get somewhat. He you know.
Thinking in this this movie
disengage. Medicalization if
you come up to these people and
you you in their face and this
is what I know thanks to the
anti for because anti. Six
seven. Ever. Balloons attacking
people cannot see face all
these kind of things they don't
work I've been through that and
I you. Every once tactics work
if you. Hey how's. In the face
really hard for you to get
punched in the face gonna fight
back in you can get the
radicalized usually those kind
of tactics further radicalized
individual drive into that
space that you're trying to get
them out of. And an attack it
that way that in my mind in
from my experience as the best
way attacking violence with
violence. Not a word. Meeting
hate with hate it's not work.
Ms and solutions and now this
is said to talk about today.
Thanks also. Working together.
That all of us together
aberration act I make on this
for. But former ext as well as
from far right for. The move
and that thing because I
understand how they think what
bottom their college prep call
it whatever you want but we do
understand caller but we don't
have a chance. Some of the
academics of. All together we
can provide the kind of support.
It takes to get these people
out of. And I want to say like.
Similar one email that left him
after. You know what we need to
have a program. And I said what
do you say your alcohol like
and- you know what I mean we
need to have a support group
because they're saying like she
was saying in this is true for
just about everybody you've
lost all your friends you've
lost your support network.
You've lost most of the people
you know some of these people
don't have strong family
support networks so everyone
they knew everyone around them.
What's in that bubble. And now
that they're out of it. They
don't have anybody so. It's
very important. That there's
programs in place to try to
help these people. So for some
it might be further any patient
AB placement. Meaning programs
get a model. The St immersion
pro. This a little bit like I
was talking about immersion
programs would be something
that works hand in hand with
community and I'll reach
leaders whether its mosques
synagogues community centers
churches things like that all
in tears and people from all
different aspects walks a life.
You take somebody from the men
and- in person. I'm or one
experience I can draw upon was
I was in a movie called- white
right the filmmakers DHEA con.
Con is an activist from the
left. From these most long from
them. The end. People in an SL
and other organise and this
woman's hi in compassion
reached. And ting them touch
them in a lot of different ways
she spent to them like so you
want to throw me out of this
country would you which throw
me up again and- one of the-
unanswered Adderley couldn't
answer. It in. Them to the car
because the night. Is asking
the question that was
unsettling. Broke down the bear
and some of the people that
were in that fit là. People
have persevered and done that
sort of thing and for her she
was a victim she was a victim
of white supremacy- I won't get
into her story of because
that's not for me to tell but
she was a victim so it takes.
His own president at amount of
compassion to be able to do
things like that it reminds me
of another woman not hope
Haidar that works with us that
parallel networks. Hope's
father was and- and hope is a
black woman her father was
murdered by a white supremacist.
And hope is probably one of the
most forgiving people. She is
the kind of forgiveness that I
don't think I could ever have
or that most people could ever
have she attends the parole
hearings for the guy that
killed our father. She's been
able to forgive and try to
understand that that sort of
thing so I think forgiveness is
a powerful powerful tool- and
I'm not suggesting we go to the
level that hope was able to go
to but that's one of the things
we do with parallel networks as
we work with. Former jihadis
former white nationalists
victims of hate that sort of
thing along with academics. And
get everybody to work together
and build this not community
because we need to replace wife
parallel networks is because
we're trying to replace. What
they have lost you know
building new network for the
people to have something. Up
positive in their life. And
actually today. Our control alt
delete hate magazine this is
something we're gonna be in Sir
tell them print issue. I had
hoped brings with but it low.
The press today the map in that
we've produced to break down
these sort of things and to get
it into the people's hands so
we can break down hate it's
written completely by farmers-
victims of hate and academics
in in these roles. Fifty
extremist let's help from these
programs. I'm to come in this
in the future. I would suggest
make. Ms mandates. Sure.
Because that will break down
the state's type old birds so
we going to do it someone has a
crack addiction problem. And
you go okay well you way for I
think there's a handful of
money in a new part. In the old.
Is in place you can't just say
what this and get this person
I've got out so. Problem solved
is done no a lot need long term
counseling they need at new
network the need a port group
or they could go back. And
that's what we're trying to
avoid. Having someone say on.
And then going right back into
the previous. Is something
that's healthy or or if and
when you do that is well making
the immersion program.
Mandatory I think would be a
pop. Does it will show them at
these other human. And they may
have I stated themselves when
they were in the nationalist
movement- but meet with these
volunteers. That help in this
type of thing I would make a
difference I really do. When
the former's have a critical
role in this because of our
under ending on reach these
people are law you know my
number down form. I somewhat
lot of people don't realize.
There's one guy said to me says.
Good thing the move brought.
All the in all the years you
were in it has brought blood
sweat and tears. It's not a
good thing is law negativity
it's a lot of it it's a rough
life it's not a good if. And.
They don't they don't even
realize it's like being lost
tunnel and not understanding
what you've really lost and
then come out and you see like.
It is like the kid they can't
see any gets new glasses or
contacts I was a kid by the
way. Dot. You know that's like
when you finally see like what
you've been missing. Change is
possible. This today. To be
able to do something like this
check pots. Real change. Born
this learn the can on learned.
Jamie. I mean these people
Tackett people not gonna help
when it is there causation.
This past the wait. I believe
that most. Less perfect we all
think we're ashamed of. A bad
thing. Yeah and I think for
everybody the dad Todd
redemption as well typically
yes. That's all today my
presentation I'd like to thank
everybody. Getting us in in
some de L. information about
background to and- what you've
experienced in your and in your
life- we're going to move out
to- quick comments and I'd like
to give my colleagues an
opportunity if they have any
questions but if you don't mind
I'd like to kick that off
asked- ask you- two questions
one is- was there was there-
you have to name names but was
there an individual or an
organization. That approached
you that- and did you suddenly
clock- or did it take some time
and then- you mention peril.
Networks and I don't imagine
that the only group out there.
Do you know how organizations
that are funded- and who who
sponsors them. Let me do one
question the time yeah the
first the first part was.
What's your sub was there a an
individual or an organization
that- reached out to you and-
it clicked suddenly or to take
some time this was something
that took me about three years
about three years and was
meeting a number of individuals
over that period of years- and
sort of breaking it down so for
me I wasn't really approached
until I was. Starting to get
out- in the past year that I
was in. I approach parallel
networks I had some contact
with some other people and-
they started talking to me
about getting out. So yes there
is other far as how the group
performed that works as a non
profit so we depend on. I don't
really know how it all works
yet because new inner. Soul I
think you probably know more
about it than I do as far as
how aye aye what you told me
tonight. And I want to thank
you. But I do know that- these
are things that. Seriously need
funding I don't know how how
the funding exactly works I'm
sure some of Michael- coworkers
and peril on that works
understand. That there's other
organizations such as life
after hate is another one-
there's a few debt. Is a few
different groups that do this
work but it's. How they get the
full thing and all but I'm too
new to it to really be able to
tell you how they how they get
some of it does come from the
private sector- I know there
was some grants that were
supposed to be going to life
after hate at some point. But.
I don't think that happened. So
yeah thank you questions. All
right there. Any forms filled
out. The one to bring those to
happen and- call people up. Yes
good thank you and- want to
submit a slip now too late-
Danny during. If you could come
and speak to the my phone. That
would be great. Well thank you
for being. For the purpose
because of two comments. And
one question but I want to
thank all of elected or.
Hearing my group list. There is
the job thank you so much for
being here but because you
don't. Really great I'm the.
Third grant with the California
over his office through
classroom you're going to meet
Mike the next week one I think
was of course eleven. A very
dear friend. Also protecting.
It speech and he was I. In
riverside. Bob. Does he want to
make sure that the defense. The
right to speak. Was Brian Levin
your friend and it was also
should direct. More things
shooting of seven do you know
the person who shoppers what's
your. Another students was
going by the FBI. Yeah
disappeared want to focus on to
join his group so I know it's
percent. With this I wanted to
ask one question and make to
come. View was. The of based it.
Or hate speech to the lives. A
close one. Many times a year I
have over four thousand
students sampling four thousand
your interview. And the sad
part of it. Percent of Muslims
reported hate speech against
them. Reported to you was- so
thank you so much for coming
here. Do you before I'm going
to do is. You want before you
nine hundred or maybe four
thousand names of people on a
daily basis or weekly basis
experiencing hate speech. The
with his. Eyes risk because we
don't know what to do with that
it doesn't look. Yeah the T.
facing but I'm also the other
one these are are expected the
other thing is another one of
my political. For more senior.
This is the only. Version
talked about it was the largest
immersion pro western United
States the best one data
brought over a dollar grant.
For the six people working
through the immersion program
to go above three. It is and of
course officials in the room.
The question to you Sir but I
hope oversee which is in this
room. We'll bring it because
they know it. What it is to
bring it back. Lives. And we
brought them all one religion.
The city is them. This to be
good so the question user what
we do one we have thought of
people reporting. In his crimes
against them what you want to
do as instructed first come to
the students. Thank you for
your comment thank you for your
question. I would say this if
you feel that there when it
comes so I hate speech. I fight
hate with hate. In a negative
way is the answer. Point.
Responding is isn't he said you
have to love. Try to befriend
try to understand intro
compassion. I would say for the
individuals who are victims of
hate crimes you have to port
crimes there's way that we can
even combat those. In our we
need we are Daly facing and
pulls are really the voiceless
because there are. Sir
political. In the in the
Hispanic or Latino community
were find are afraid to come
forward because the rate of the
repercussions of. Partition
were being again. Freight the
middle to end this is goes the
most to me also- individuals
are afraid because it will be
targeted. Hello this man is
that Mr. Everyone in the
voiceless. It's not our job to
pick a side of the one side I
Republican press our job right.
That we live. Hey in courage
that report the crime. At the
ranch read in a place. And we
can figure. Let me add another
suggestion because in some
thing is to as prevalent. I
have no doubt that it that it
it. A you know a survey is a
good way of trying to- assessed
and then show the- extent to
which an issue a exists in a
community whether it's a
college community or city or
neighborhood. And so you may
want to look at developing a
way to. Seve that kind of
information and categorizing it
in a way that is separate and
apart from the criminal justice
system. Just some good news
real quick our our leave our
lead story showed thank god
last year anti Muslim cry
finally went down found that to.
Twenty seven even. Anti assault
Muslim still was higher than
that hello anti Arab crimes
unfortunately with seen
something he's twenty seventeen
to. But hope god was on their
figure it will come Kerr's data
and our data showing a decline
at the mother I'm twenty
eighteen I of course it's
always to scan number come down
but what we're looking for our
long term trend lines were
continuously goes down and
doesn't bounce around a high
number. Our next to a comment
from a night out Lawrence. I
I'm in Iran and first of our
most I enjoy this. And I Philip
this conversation kids in to
continue on like. Hopefully we
can have some more change in
the future so. Although we went
through the hate crimes and
everything like that. Did not
go over was white privilege
that I went gov. So I exam what
I put. Many people though it
exist and so one example of my
privileges the fact that we
have. Former White soliciting
here that is for you to be. The
all around too pretty much.
Take to in a way cool and so.
Sample of our crews with use
with how. Anybody know to mayor
rice. So even more examples I
keep is of an armed boys and on
our black men who were killed
by police I want used to be a
rice. Temple and so the fact
that. By the bees. Again and we
had a nineteen year old white
by the name of Nicholas crews
who went into a squirrel and
murdered seventeen people and
so nineteen year old boy walked
out alive breeding and
everything apps for a twelve
year old black boy who had a
toy gun was gunned down so that
their- love why approved. And I
want. Rainy days and that's
something that we on is talk
about more thank you. Thank you
very much. One of the reasons.
That there's more than the
average security areas that
were I'm concerned. Outside
folks might want to take
advantage of the fact that
we're talking about this very
sensitive topic Bob says more
than the usual more than the
common amount of security for a
select committee or for. Any
committee even in that in the
in the capital but that's large
they're here- but thank you
for. In that up. Next we have
just in case. Close short good
evening does us all sat down I
want to commend you guys on
this event that you guys put
together for like it's very
necessary for us to talk about
this all want to thank all you
guys on the panel. First and
foremost- but I sat there long
and hard thinking about a
question a housing company and
ask. En I mean although I can
come down here and- of the
things that. I wanted to touch
on is one of things that. Even
to is. You can't fight hate
with hate you guys. Touched on
that. Earlier but to me. Of
what do you suppose that.
People of non color when you
have these. All right movements
these national groups and
they're coming down in your
cities and their come down here
and what do you. Are you not
supposed. Not supposed to fix
anything or to do anything and
then finally start to speak up
in a- manner you get shut down
and send away. IT so how do you
expect. Us as a people of color
to dance progress in America.
We quite frankly were allowed
to a lot of us come from
brown's were were already
fighting a system that isn't
built for us in America the
first place. So we do have
these. Groups come that you say
and you tell us. It's not gets
a fight hate with hate but what
if but what what has sitting
around goddess all these years.
Where where has that got us
look look up. One you guys as a
pan. The answer that what. As a
people can we do to combat this
that. You run for office you
get college degree vote. The
court ruled time to time. I
know that there is a movement
of people. Stand with. It's
bigger than you think the
loudest most of voices of hate.
I'm sure have one and I can
tell you that the person who
made me going to do. Bottom. He
was a segregated school and
living in an attic and he went
to the dean and the dean said
would separate putting. You in
will record. He read. You do.
Assemblymember midday. I can
add something to that. First
when it comes to fighting hate
sound are pro testing thing. In
itself is something that I'm
sure Jeff will attempt to they
they knew that they expected
that they would up would not.
Hundred counter protesters show
up who do you think got
arrested. Testers because
usually anger lead to violence
which to the rest that do
anybody any good all it does is
get the **** in the class white
I'm assist. So that's terminate
those rallies. I and knowing
what and so there are there are
other ways to pressure concerns
now we have so to media where
you can go online and calmly
discuss this is Jeff said maybe
you try to make friends with
somebody maybe not one of those
right. Please or or something
else. The negativity that comes.
Of some of those same does not
do any of any it only benefits
the extra. To respond to a
young people thank you. I marks
Ted then I am happy to be here
and encourage. All folks to
stand. But it needs and I agree
the young people us. To it hi
it happens because we do live.
Lee in a races IT this is Susan
permeates of our ours we see it
everywhere see it everywhere we
see it. We see an institution.
Unfortunately we continue to
see it. There is spectrum.
Eight and we are looking at
right now you know the most a
strong arm of hate. You can go.
When I read today you know
someone CA are. Of color in
line perhaps in the first class
and asking. The right. Where we
see in rivers. Next may by the
conduct. Of the metro train
another pop school. Going do
you wanna. In the group it up
the girl stood up. Tape those
remarks. She then came to my
office I. At the metrolink
resident a to come to. We had a
meet. You know by videotaping
and she got it on the news so I
think it's incumbent upon us to
every single time we see some
infringe upon. Question whether
we belong on or not. Certain
places stand. Do it fully. But
is but we need to stand up.
Know what to say to you when-
we have these rallies and there
were fighting and things like
that the people in the movement
based on that absolutely
thrives on it so when there was
violence they could get a
chance to fight. Remember rally
was in. And the police. Kiley
for nothing. The. Out there to
hear it you know like they say
like el we've got free speech
in this country but you're
speaking and nobody hears it
you know like a tree falling
press no one hears it I can see
that on all the route is I ever
doing past twenty seven years
that route the city where there
was hardly any be there but-
press it was the most
demoralizing from the
standpoint of all. Right now
the list. Ever been at whereas
store. We have fistfight. And
the battles in like that eyes
let me I need to do that again.
You know we can we have that
this work. Was boring. So it's
like we don't feed into that
because I. Think it's- out of
the movement I think. It keeps
people there if there's- a
peaceful protest. Since but I
got like to salute. Complete
warrant for to test. Islands
then it just blows up the water.
I want to tell you. So proud of
having the. I think change
happen because of you. The way
use those of us who live in
have expected so many different
things our reaction was
different and the dead. About
what would you all do. Excited
that day. You you hold us to
tell you talk about privilege
we have to talk about that
because that is important.
Don't in in the room. No pun
intended. Those are the sorts
of things we have to talk about
and knowing young. Is that are
that are getting grease to
becoming the judges that are
becoming the elected officials
things are going to change
because of you. They're going
to change because of you not in
spite of you but because of
you. I thank you for being here.
The each of these questions
and- general topics are that
taught the subject of a course.
They are they are exercise does.
But I think. If you don't mind
my. Calling you by first name.
Bob on compassion of so you can
confront and be compassionate.
And I do think that we have to
confront. Race I'm sorry some
anti some Islamophobia Walker
said. But then what fall. What
fall those are saying that's
not acceptable. That's were I'm
where what we heard from if-
gives me some hope and some
ideas since fought about where
you might go from here which to
me for this fall. A series of
select. Committee hearings this
kind of struggle it's- takes a
lot work to put together an
event like this but we're- with
that we do be a friend you know
it's all great to sit here. And
here information but what we do
and information how do we move
forward and way that's positive
and helps change the world-
thank you for the question. I
we've cut- still have a few of
these will try to move this
along we've got- because- it's
now six oh four. And we're
gonna Ernest. But let's let's
keep this going Sherri Gilliam.
Followed by Nicholas first.
Your call two names the time if
you can read it is might walk.
I have two older than most
people here I combined what
what I don't want to. Be on
that- there's a twenty five
million. The state okay three
hundred twenty million when I
see the white supremacists-
rally have hand four hundred
when I have staff people give
me three thirteen. Eighteen
twenty two yeah thirty seven
fifty. When I look the police
shooting the mails black people
whatever hundred twenty five
hundred this is all the other
night. But the same time look
this room seven hundred people
living here. Time six that's
how many people get killed the
Chicago Bulls. Eight thousand
in here black kids are killing
each other the inner cities. We
do not have a white problem
what we have is a violence
problem. And it's fine for you
guys. I sit here I do except
talk only as I go for centuries
in thirty minutes ever so I
want to try to. Help our kids
especially yep avail yourself
more information if somebody
give your percentage. Don't
percentage look number. It is
unacceptable what's on our
communities and trying to blame
it on whites. A prince or hate
I grew up in the fifties and
sixties and the fact. Had real
hatred and real racism.
Lynchings shootings you can go
to school with certain people I
was blessed you can go to
certain bathrooms my dad mom in
up in Florida the legion
capital of the world they have
some Hollister second change.
Would really change your mind
and with that being said at
that point there was thousand
people that were steps whatever
you can barely community
without fear of some
Appalachian are killing you and
there was no loss protect them.
We have grown pass at one I
wonder when they come a day
when I look the kids hear what
they're saying. And my main. I
have to assn who's bothered you.
Most you gotta be good luck
unless you live in inner
cities. You can one go to
school when you want. It
restaurants where you want you
know use a bathroom where you
want. Who these people that our
body is so bad on you we don't
have a the space. This can
happen allow that in a certain
way you acted when you get out
of anything at any point could
cost you your life if stepped
on a line. Okay my dad and his
friends now and then eighties
and nineties. If you ever watch
barbershop. Them near the
happiest in a women I've ever
seen let me talk I said how do
they have that. In their heart
much hatred. Racism what
directed toward them what they
had morning thing they have
strong families and
relationships what we don't
have anymore. I want you to
challenge your professors what
they say Ste do you. And they
table assists six go the
library get your group together
get you some books I feel two
books and go to that social
media Tweedy and Facebook and
all that kind of. Garbage
values. Get real information at
ask your professor questions.
When they pay you fifty set up.
Born you look at that the
percent maybe two people. That
is. Not right for them to do
that and give you that false
answer and what they know is
most. He is not a you know read
study. You have no idea what
what they're saying with the
top. What information out there
go also to your history you're
not being taught history more.
And how black people really.
And what how you were treated
whatever but challenge them. To
do it challenge yourself what
you're doing education is fine
keep that. Up is that with an
argument we're so far removed
from the slave ship. A lot you
have idea. What they were
slaves. At one point so I don't
have a problem when you see it
what's going to rights that
white supremacy which three of
four people. Is that how my
Charlotte. Top of Chicago. This
room is about a hundred chair
so in. Time that sticks. That's
me black kids are killing each
other in just a cog. Eight
thousand every year. And I'm
sorry about these people. That
are on this board I see they
these nice look cushy areas
some you don't whatever but
they did that the oldest but
you'll get them. Ladies be and
go home. Lackey is Betty we
don't yeah. Don't live like
that. So get your education
can. Get more in your community
find was going on share your
professors and they don't want
to debate me in my little.
Girls and stuff to get this be
a cold different coverage will
do that all of the caliphs. But
we need to have some under
discussion and not just people
just you know famous. Things
whatever have debate between
two groups. Leaving give you
real information so you're
going to be informed but I love
you guys I'm older. I want you
guys really that flourished
your education. I want you to.
Make decisions on the form
information. And continuous
original question. But I just
felt. Hard I had to say that
thank you very much. The
perspective. The flowers all by
Randall. Días. Hello hello I'm
so first say thank you for a
actually taking I'm just as
because I'm not be with that
resistance I'll take the time
to I was the only college. Here
but a big amount of us are
college students. Take the time
to talk to us our boat I really
wanted to was for the- to
German at the end- I know you
said combating hate with hate I
do agree with that that's not
okay- but- how as group that as
me growing up in inner city.
Are identifying as a white male
and- female- to be hated Bob
why cited from because my
father's black. How do we go
against. Will win like for
instance the black lives
matter. Is only after that they
became notices fixing offices
that are wrong. But then came a
blue lives matter movie and a
white lies about a movie and a-
large management. That's
basically the says kind of
covering up the sins of the-
shop. If you take it apart like
people. So the end and I
respect what you with the lady
I said I was that bad indeed.
Are we still have like black
males I know from a from
Bigelow California for me
California- I've had multiple
of my friends be gunned down by
police officers. Whether that
be whether that be for no
apparent reason or for some
reason at all. It is still
wrong. The fact that I'm I'm
dropped in my home city and if
I get bored over an officer
tells me. That the reason why
he pulled me over is because I.
Look like I belong in a certain
area. Is absolutely wrong. So
it and I do want to commend you
for Stephanie Stephanie. Into
the spaces- because it is hard
for somebody who's- who's hated
black people come here talk. In
a little black people about
why. Roth so I do commend you
on that but in a day I don't
know like what like what it.
Does to do as as you. Are
always not heard. Of it basis.
When we got people base. There
are protests. Okay thank you
for your state your comment. On
this question I can only answer.
Number one I am African
American to almost of what.
Number three I'm also. So the
question. The same questions.
Have an address the officer one
it is unacceptable for an
officer approach somebody say
you like you don't. We don't
teach it. That's an internal.
Once it's not recommended there
to know a lot about being out
of. The result this is. I want.
No word three does violence
published anything ever. Every
great leader accomplished
accomplice. It's never ever is
listen ever in any way. Any
land. Everyone has the right to
test. Jeff said. Organizations
a form and they want to get
together one response because
they know they're going to get
a response if not there. Who
were. Protesting they're
talking to themselves. When it
comes to. Thirty I'm sorry. Yes
against protests. It there's
nothing wrong with protests we
are at this point where we are
in this nation you have indeed
who do not look like you in
positions that would. Have
been. Forty fifty six years ago.
At all the- I'm fortunate. Sir
because there was a time that
somebody look like me was not a
law enforcement officer it just
wasn't I'm for it because we
have individuals who are
status. Members. Nor would not
look like you are aye. For it
is the what. This single life
matters when the numbers of
statistics when they come out
it's not popular to say that is
the test. Police officers
search more white Americans.
It's not it's not popular about
that you can have a shooting
somewhere in our nation the
media is only gonna show one
aspect. They will show on
others. Sir. All I will also
tell you this everything was
shooting every in every every
incident. Late you have to look
at. Independently it's not all
down in the- it happened within
in the word. Or New York or
Florida or county San Marino.
You can't love everything the
same. All protest. Because what
at the other day every does
matter if. Bill especially he
is more. We're off to my
department in our jail. The
certain sees before we have
more calling from. Bernard job
duties all the more officers
but we don't talk about that.
Life is a life and it doesn't.
It is a thousand watt told or
one life a mother fears of
every race. Is still hurting.
Thank you for the answer. The
cut off but we were given the
room until fifteen. The court
also. A major. We had Randall
and state keener- but wanted
to- op questions or comments I
pledges have ask your brief as
possible but we do want. Okay.
Users about- then in a or
whatever believe that but. Time
we said it seems like we get
our hands. And we put that the
police officers at the we get
shot. Free. Stand up and others
have when I get this so. And
it's possible to answer that
question hopefully but assembly
member may give it away I
think. The deserves an answer
and I appreciate you asking and
so on I am proud to be a co
author of assembly bill three
ninety two the use of force I
am Cooper co author of that
bill. That was signed by the
governor this year. Changing
the law. How police should act
been deadly use of force so I'm
high school teacher top with ms
movie share here my students
were stopped had said that on
the curb you know because they
were in the wrong place and
they were the wrong color so I
respect. Your quest. I know
what we're talking about here
has a you know we could talk
about it- for many more hours.
I think Skinner questions.
Assembly. Trying to address the
issue that you bring up. Thank
you. The last we have sage
keener. Hello I'm sage Greiner
two questions I'm sorry I know
it's gonna be a little shorter-
once reject that- throughout
your prison he referred to the
national socialist movement as
Martin these organs and what.
Is the frequently a man I can I
have a question rather rather
as saying this the organ is
once a part of- is a particular
reason why you. Said that. Or
is any reason behind it. That's
a good question now it force I
haven't. Times are when I'm
Madera creek say my former
organization. Very very clear.
It is my former realization I
have nothing to do with the
organisers. Thank you I'll be
more mindful thank you. And my
sense is first after. You had
said but of what they're not
another. He crimes that happen.
But for being honest and-
respect all enforcement. Is
there project and while there's
no urgency. AB props there's
reasons with- but they have not
mother the rest is it as we- as
a society. That is pushed aside
more times and often. It's not
just for your notes. But I can.
When. The call for service they
need right now. Our. We
anything unless somebody
reported so that's the first
set to report it. I don't have
an answer we would not want to
report something. Right. And
that's the best thing I can say.
Just real for the first. Your
of justice statistics three
years fifty four now report we
what do you poor. To report to
the police or. Organizations
can report you I'm gonna be
working friends with the
Mexican consulate so we can get
people to read and which one
think is Latino serving
institution we need to reach
the Latino community our
numbers consistently show that
the reporting among Latinos
does not appear to register
with portion the population so
what we're gonna. Our center
here with me working with the
groups law enforcement as well
folks in the legislature and
Ste thank you thank you very
much. For the- please give a
hand- everyone who helped put
this together including. You
San Bernardino- my chief of
staff Josh Kirby's my staff.
Stewart was on with DD xikar or
a temper who's not here only
because he's a vacuum waited.
From what the for burning right
now so to help yeah and sitting
to my left up Melissa Koffler
who had a lot of. Here's an
American. Thank you all for
being here and does with us to
the. Thank you to our panelists
this is been in late may
helpful. If you give us your
email we will be apprised of.
When and where the next hearing
will okay thank you